und ich sage auch heute und jetzt in
dieser Situation die Mehrheit der
Muslime in der Bundesrepublik beteiligt
sich nicht an diesen radikalen aufrufen
diejenigen insbesondere
rechtsextremistische Kräfte die schon
seit langem versuchen gegen Muslime zu
hetzen hier die Gesellschaft zu spalten
und auch ich sag mal den die den Saat
des Hasses zu sehen äh die fühlen sich
natürlich jetzt besonders noch mal
in die Position gebracht dass sie jetzt
auf dieser ganzen emotionalen Debatte
den allgemeinen Hass gegen Muslime
schüren können und da it im Grunde die
Arbeit auch der Islamisten machen denn
deren Interesse ist es dass wir die
gemäßigten und die hier zu Hause
angekommenen wieder abspalten dass wir
sie radikalisieren und deswegen ist es
unsere Aufgabe auch meine Aufgabe als
Chef einer Sicherheitsbehörde dass wir
für den Schutz auch der muslimischen
Communities einstehen und das auch tun
und ich denke das wird auch eine der
schweren Aufgaben in der nächsten Zeit
sein